I stopped taking it after we
broke up to get my make my body a break
from the hormones
I don't think you understand like I I
seriously can't deal with this right now
I have okay okay Danny I'm sorry it's so
stressful for you so that's not what I
mean where are you yelling because I'm
frustrated and we're both
yelling
you healed first
clear I couldn't barely pay rents
in the band
I can't be in South America when you're
having a baby because I can't South
America yeah
Brazil and Argentina
what
we're just skinny
it's not the first of two openers it's
nothing what am I talking about I feel
like a talking about my
band right now who cares about my band I
care about your band you care about your
band
you should
I
love your band
I love you
and I don't want to be some cliche of an
absentee father either my family will
disown me
foreign
yeah that's
that's not the same as loving me I do
love you
you know that Clary
okay
um
the timing's terrible obviously yeah
we're not even together
this isn't that hard to figure out
I mean this is how we got back together
we always knew this would be the reason
exactly
I'd have to give a music
I'd have to I'd have to give a desk job
or wherever it gives benefits like what
are my skills what what can I even do I
have to go back to school get a
degree Danny stop just stop for a second
it's okay
no it's not it's okay
we broke up for a reason
and we need to go out
and we need to live our lives you go on
tour kill Argentina kill
Brazil and I'm gonna
I'm gonna go to Iceland and climb a
glacier or something
I'm gonna live my life
and I think you should live yours
[Music]